what's up guys we're from finiti today  we're experimenting with a higher net we  have three different setups let's start  with the first one  [Music]  it was a roller on this table  [Music]  that's a good one  [Music]  well  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  Oh  oh good one good one almost worked out  we rehearse that like 10 times a day  workouts you should always be expecting  that I do something weird like that  [Music]  come on and guys we have lot of crazy  videos coming out so don't forget to hit  subscribe so you don't miss out  don't know that's broken ball  [Music]  that was a good one  [Music]  good boy point  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  oh no it's sit weird because I can't see  you at all yeah  [Music]  yeah  [Music]  that would have been an interesting life  [Music]  ah I'm hitter the Nets yeah we have some  pretty interesting table set up today  hope you guys enjoyed this video  yeah I remember to subscribe my child  here on what your previous episodes  there